cbs news medical consultant dr david
agus joins us now with more on the
pandemic
he's in los angeles david that was a
striking number that tom hansen just
spoke about so far right now we know
that three states
reported cases of the uk variant of
covet 19.
uh now they're eight so what should we
know about this well there are two
variants the south african and the uk
varian the south african is the one i'm
really worried about there's no question
the uk variant is in the united states
eight states reporting
but there probably are many many more
we're not
sequencing enough rna of the virus to
actually know which variant
it is and i bet you the south african
variant is here too so we have to be
aware we have to vaccinate
as much as we can as quick as we can
yeah we heard the number from tom there
friday president-elect biden
said that he would release all of the
vaccine instead of keeping it in storage
and holding back that supply what's your
view on this
i've been talking almost daily to the
biden team and the cova team and and
certainly
every vaccine that is available should
be given to somebody it should not sit
in the freezer anywhere
whether a state or the federal
government so the sooner we get the
initial vaccine out there the better
we're going to do with one shot
you get about 60 percent of immunity
after 10 to 14 days
and then hopefully weeks later you get
that second shot when you can really get
the full immunity
but we have to get it rolling out better
across the country
right so but doctor the question is then
this is the rollout has been slower than
many people hoped you do you see a
significant improvement in the weeks
ahead
and i think maybe more importantly if
we're looking at dates and timelines
here a few weeks ago the government said
that
they hoped by june everyone who wanted a
vaccine
would be able to get one do you believe
that is still possible
yeah i think it is possible i think and
i and many others are pushing to
aggressively approve the johnson johnson
vaccine
as well as the astrazeneca oxford
university vaccine
those vaccines are much easier to give
you don't have to freeze them and they
can be given in regular doctor's offices
instead of in big hospitals or large
parking lots
and so i think if we have more of a
supply distributed across the country we
can do it
you know the first couple weeks were
very very slow and i will tell you just
myself getting that first vaccine it
took me 15 minutes for them to get
through the software and get me
registered because it was the beginning
when i went for my second shot it took
seconds and i went in and i was out
and doctor in the 30 seconds we have
left here if someone is sitting at home
watching and waiting for this vaccine
should they be calling their doctor
should they be waiting for a call what
should people be doing right now
who have not been vaccinated every state
is setting their own criteria
by age by medical condition etc so look
on your
state public health website and you'll
get a sense of where you are
in line and based on that you know
what's going to happen in some states
you're doing it at hospitals
others in pharmacies and they're going
to announce it my gut is when the biden
administration takes over there will be
more of a federally directed program
on how to distribute it across the
country okay dr david agus as always
thank you very much